and know you've done a lot of television
you tell us what is the typical day like
for an actor on set nerves in the
morning you show up to work I much
prefer getting there early I like to be
there you know right after the second ID
or whoever's running base camp is just
you know opening it out it helps me to
come in land plus you know the drives
out here it's much easier to do it five
o'clock in the morning than it is at
7:30 so I'd rather bite the bullet and
get there really early you know and grab
a little coffee or breakfast and then go
over my go over what I am doing again
and also check those new pages because
you know they come in with sides in the
trailer and I found a number of times
that the sides that I learned and
studied have been changed that morning
so I don't want to I don't want to
surprise I want to have an opportunity
to digest that you know I'll get in my
wardrobe and I'll go see hair and makeup
and you know the makeup trailer is
fascinating central Nexus for everything
I would say the last people you want to
piss off for the makeup trailer and hair
and makeup you don't want to do that
because everything is going through
there they know everything you can get a
good reputation there or you can get a
bad reputation there so let's go in
let's make nice that's let's see them
let's here let's listen to them because
and they're there they're colorful and
they're funny and they're you know and
they're and they're taking care of us
they're you know they're trying to put
the best foot forward I always asked you
know I asked for two things and they're
always gracious about giving it to me
and I always quote the Michael Caine
line because he said it to me when we
were working on second hand lines when
they asked me if I wanted mascara and he
leaned over in the makeup chair any
system if I can't see your eyes you
might as well be doing radio and I said
to do to make a person I'd really like
mascara please so you know
learning from the from the the master
but minoo you come out of there and then
I usually try to just sit and relax and
and and touch things if I'm if I'm still
needling a scene I'll go back and need a
little a little bit right then because
then they're gonna come and get me and
when I get to the set I always try to
make friends with the camera guys they
are the guys to me for one thing they're
you know they're salt of the earth and
they see it first and I I find myself
honestly checking with them I'll look
and see if they got a tape going you
know what I mean
because if it if if I see a concern or
something on them then then I retool a
little bit and it if we've worked
together for a while you know I'll say
Tom how was that yo go or ask for
another one you know but so Minh to have
allies on the set and really respect
what those guys do their remarkable
crews and they work so much harder than
I work that I like to get a sense of who
they are the property people and you
know the people who are looking after us
and the exchanges are happening and you
know do you have the gun yeah I got the
gun can we look at it how can I feel
like my hands sure and then what it does
for me more than anything else it allows
me to create a space that I can work in
usually I'm a guest on the television
show so if I can very quickly ask one of
the leads about their process or just
express an interest in them because the
truth of the matter is they're doing a
lot of heavy lifting they just need to
know they can be comfortable with me
that and then they're willing for me to
do my job which is to add or take off
some of the weight that they're having
to carry I think that's the the
character actors job we help them
deliver it and I make a concerted effort
and mostly it's selfish because all it
does is creates a comfortable space for
me to work in so that when I've got to
do that I can be relaxed I can be part
of the part of the family they can trust
me and we go and you shoot your scenes
and you know between scenes you go back
and refresh on the next scene that
you've got coming up and really try to
jettison the last one to let it go
there's not time to needle in ball over
you know and just keep doing that till
the end of the day go home get rest
drink a lot of water and get up and do
it again the next day
you